in these videos we are going to be
talking about the document object model
also known as the Dom the do and you'll
see that referred to a lot particularly
as you work with jQuery which we'll get
into a little bit later the document
object model is the browser's internal
programmatic representation of the web
page what that means is you can
manipulate the document object model and
change the page without actually going
in and changing any of the HTML now you
have to use a write language like
JavaScript or a library of JavaScript
like jQuery to access and talk to the
Dom but it can be a really powerful tool
both as a programmer and as a user of
websites technically the dong is also an
API if you're not familiar with api's
that's fine
but remember this is a type of API api's
are really powerful and can do a lot of
things if you've already been using
javascript and particularly jQuery you
already been working with the Dom it's
pretty intuitive once you get used to a
language like jQuery let's talk about
some examples of a document object model
manipulation these examples are pure
JavaScript just pure vanilla JavaScript
document that get element by ID and then
the ID is something that maybe you've
seen before in some of the earlier
challenges element get elements by tag
name is another example and if you want
to create something totally new document
dot create element and then the name of
that element you don't have to remember
this this is not a lesson on how to
manipulate the document object model
just that sort of how it's possible you
understand the concept and if you
already are using some of these examples
maybe you can connect those dots a
little bit better let's talk about some
jQuery examples for this example in
jQuery there's the same jQuery notation
with the dollar sign and in here it's
got the hash tag from the class so here
is selecting the box to class and it's
appending adding the string this is now
in box two so if you already done the
jQuery challenges you might be like oh
yeah I recognize that
kind of stuff what you've been doing is
manipulating the document object model
to actually change what's being
displayed on a webpage without changing
the HTML what I want you to take away
from this video is in the document
object model is technically an API that
is inside of your browser it is easy to
use so even if you can't wrap your head
around the concept of document object
model necessarily don't be intimidated
by it don't be afraid to start using
languages like JavaScript and the
library like jQuery to start changing
the context of a page without changing
the actual HTML when you do that using
these languages or other languages you
are manipulating the document object
model